Papa John's Pizza sales have dropped off
recently the company's CEO is blaming
the NFL players who kneeled in protest
during the anthem that's what he says
yes yes Papa John's is the official
pizza of the NFL I didn't know they had
an official pizza but if you're gonna
have one make sure it's Papa John yeah
they probably have an official pob tie
yeah exactly
anyway Papa John's is the official piece
of the NFL so what they're saying is
that once the players took a knee people
turned off their TVs and missed out on
all their great Papa John's commercials
yeah now seems like a bit of a stretch
to me but Papa John's just released a
new commercial actually looks like
they're trying to make the best of this
situation take a look hey America Papa
John's gets it
you love nila nila nila nila
but Papa John's knows you hate one thing
about it soare needs and Papa John's has
the Cure Papa John pizzas are the
perfect cushion for all your kneeling
occasions protests in the garden or in
that perfect moment Papa John's is there
and introducing kneeling calzones
extra comfort with extra meat so
remember Papa John's next time you drop
a joint to protest police brutality and
institutionalized racism
[Applause]
you